Die Übung AIREX 2018 ist die größte Übung der Luftstreitkräfte in diesem Jahr.
Am 21. und 22. März 2018 trainierten die
Soldaten die Evakuierung von Personen
mittels Lufttransport. Die Übung fand im
Raum Wien und Niederösterreich statt und
dient der Vorbereitung auf den
österreichischen EU-Ratsvorsitz in der
zweiten Jahreshälfte 2018.
Die Herausforderung einer Evakuierung ist es, dass wir eine
große Anzahl an Luftfahrzeugen, wir
sprechen hier von 12 Hubschraubern die
im gleichen Raum operieren,
gemeinsam mit Jets und Flächenfliegern,
dass wir diese große Anzahl an
Luftfahrzeugen so koordinieren. Dass wir das
entsprechend vorbereiten, jeder seine Rolle kennt, jeder weiß was er in welcher Situation tun muss, um das Drehbuch mit allen
Eventualitäten ablaufen zu lassen.